is another week and it is another insect
swallowing story that we have in the
city of toronto and you might be next
elsa
watch out so early this month a clip of
ontario premiere doug ford went viral as
he swallowed a b
during a live press conference take a
look
not coming from the
government per se but the premier it's
coming from the health sector
holy crap
i just swallowed a bee
it was the noise for me that's right it
was that was the
and now it was our very own our friend
our legend farah nasser of global
national who swallowed a fly mid news
broadcast and this girl she kept it all
together while live on tv a professional
eight weeks of non-stop torrential rain
a national emergency has been invo
has been invoked but the weather in
pakistan extreme weather is alarming
nity garcia reports
and joining us now is farinasa herself
come on in here walk on look at this i
know you get a hold of us it's like
great
this is what it took to get on your show
again
all i had to do was i would have done
this like a year ago right longer
amazing yeah okay can you walk us
through step by step i don't mean to be
but can you please from the music
what happened okay so i saw the fly
flying around at the beginning of the
news and uh i think you guys sometimes
have flies in this studio we definitely
do okay yeah so we do in our in our in
our new studio as well and i was like
not today's flight getaway not today i'm
like i'm not gonna let you distract me
not i thought it was more going to go
into the lens if that happens you know
the fly becomes big
so i was more concerned about that and
then the next thing i knew it was just
in my throat like didn't even hit the
teeth just went straight and you can't
even see it in the video which is so
crazy it was so sneaky this fly oh my
gosh okay so the big question is though
did you swallow it and is it buzzing
around still
very possible yes very possible but also
um yeah i did swallow it because i felt
it so that intro if you saw the end i i
i tossed it to the to the reporter's
piece because i couldn't finish there
was like another paragraph
i was like but you are such a pro you
handled that listen last night i'm not
even lying last night i was walking home
from the dollar store and a bug flew in
my eye and i said to my partner do i
have a bug in my eyes like oh yeah it's
right there just put your finger in it
and get it out i'm like i'm not doing
that it's like putting dirty hands no
it disappeared there was no one there to
fish out the fly now you've got some
great traction off this like it is gone
all around north america if not it's
it's going everywhere right yeah it's
strange i think people just want
something to laugh at and i think with i
mean you and i talk about this all the
time like news is so heavy so it's
really nice to just give people a laugh
even if give them my expense i mean it's
fine give them one thing
yeah but it was it's it's it's been
pretty funny and and you know maybe like
maybe i'll be good on survivor because
it didn't it grossed me out it really
grossed me out but
i i handled it you think you could do
survivor i don't know
wow i mean i'd have to train with you oh
i would do that
no no no no no train no i know you
wouldn't do it i'm saying i'd have to
get stronger all right
and then um yeah and then i'd have to i
don't know yeah the bug thing is maybe i
but but i didn't like it it was gross it
was disgusting i felt the whole
newscaster your children must think
you're so cool yeah no they were making
the joke about the follow a spider and
you know today it works well with spider
to kill the flies and a cat oh that's
funny the kids came up with that yeah
they were they were like disgusted with
me yeah i love it so much thank you so
much for joining us so good and kudos to
you you handled that like such a pro i
probably would have you would have done
the same thing you both would have done
the exact freaked out
yes i would have failed i wouldn't have
done the same thing and listen this
almost happened to me and i could not
keep myself together because it was all
around me it was during a recent
interview i did with lady camden here
take a look and we will see you next
time bye
i'm a big believer in the universe
ariana grande
this fly speaking of um silent but
deadly this this fly is upstaging us
just wants to be in this so it's like i
wanna want some screen time what are the
colors of the canadian flag this fly
it's coming for me now